there are so huh her ass yeah you know
you it's what my [ __ ] dialogue with
that she huh okay hello everybody
welcome to another muffin food review
and I'm excited today because I gets to
eat one of my favorite favorite foods in
this whole world I'm talking about this
food I think every day to the day I die
every day every [ __ ] day and I
wouldn't complain because this food can
be trends morphus is amorphous eyes and
anything that you want it to be we're
talking about sandwiches [ __ ]
sandwiches now there are so many
different sandwich spots in LA that I
could talk about so it was hard to
narrow it down so this is just only
sandwich video number one of many but
today we are gonna do three of my
favorite sandwiches in Los Angeles and
actually one of them is a new comer well
enough jibber-jabbering and let's get to
mention munching first sandwich my
friends now I gotta tell you I love this
sandwich I'm talking about if Muriel the
woman that I love and this sandwich was
hanging off a cliff but ii guess going
for that sandwich yeah
when i first came to LA um I didn't know
what to expect
didn't know what to expect in sandwiches
I just been making my own sandwiches and
little did I know they're almost [ __ ]
it up because I should not make my own
sandwiches I should just come to large
Mont wine and deli yes words is located
at you asked [ __ ] Larchmont I just
said it so let's start with this one my
friends let's crack this [ __ ] open
I'm a collector you know what the pay
yeah oh my it's a prosciutto sandwich
what is prosciutto you ask my friends
well any Italian [ __ ] out there will
tell you hey if you don't know what
prosciutto is you clearly hate Italy
prosciutto is a cured ham meaning it
comes from the hind leg of the pig now
it's not cooked it's cured in salt which
is why it has like this translucent like
look to it and you see that little white
stuff right there that's that delicious
cured fat oh my god inside of this we
have olive oil we have balsamic vinegar
we have check this out
mozzarella fresh mozzarella - and with
my sandwich make sure make sure when you
go there because it doesn't come with
this get the prosciutto and ask for
sun-dried tomato spread and you will
[ __ ] blow me mmm guy or girl I can't
you know what you teasing me right now
I'll tell you I'll tell you to you oh
you bet okay
Jesus Chuy punchy baguette soft on the
inside
crunchy and firm holds everything
together we have that spicy arugula we
have that creamy mozzarella we have that
buttery salty prosciutto and then on top
of that you have this delicious creamy
sun-dried tomato spread
you hear the crunch of the baguette
that's what I'm looking for in about
that this is like an Italian slice
Parisian dream I'll tell you this when I
was in Paris I didn't find a sandwich I
like better than this
Oh blasphemy oh did I say it yes I did
Paris [ __ ] you beat this sandwich mmm
hmm hmm that salty buttery delicious
prosciutto shines right through we mean
with that strong balsamic taste it's
just right there then if you want more
prosciutto by all means go ask them to
add some more it cost you a little extra
but it might be worth for you if you
want that extra salty goodness Oh mom
with the sandwich too by the way I
almost forgot we get these Cornish owns
or baby pickles is like Cornish owns
luck and Clara Clara Chung you know our
amazing musician she corrected me she
was like are you gonna grab the
cornichons
I was like [ __ ] you mean baby pickles
Cornish sounds or love her though
fantastic
Oh delicious and then we had these
wonderful olives mmm take the pit out
leave it on the side grab the sandwich
again mm-hmm you know people out there
who don't put mayonnaise in their
sandwiches or then put any spread or
olive oil or anything I'm gonna ask you
who hurt you hmm who touched you as a
child what happened to you huh
come on now don't like mayonnaise
jeez man it is delish you know people
say white people only like man it's not
true Asian people have managed to mmm
get your sandwich put it in a nice
picnic basket well glass of wine share a
wedge your girlfriend tell her that you
made it especially for her have a little
charcuterie board with cheese's and
mustard and what
give her a Christmas a baby this
sandwich is for you just as hard to this
brother so is my penis what you tell me
right now if Tim didn't say that you
wouldn't laughing this suck is Nick
please creamy mozzarella right there
that's soft mozzarella if you get that
dehydrated dry [ __ ] that's made for
snaps [ __ ] that [ __ ] man get this the
fresh one still in its way
next up my friends is a local Pasadena
favorite of mine now this place was
introduced to me by a former employee
named Danielle she's a piece of [ __ ]
just kidding Danielle hello and thank
you for introducing the sandwich to me
because it changed my [ __ ] life
this rose ain't right here it's from
Spain my brother got it for me thinking
like okay might as well have it with
this delicious sandwich because you know
I'm feeling a little whiny a little vino
I've been no fit look up what's up what
the [ __ ] that is from Spain I don't know
why I maintain the wrong language
without further ado let's talk about
this sandwich and let's crack this [ __ ]
open because this sandwich is from a
spot called er a cafe and when you go
there and you order this sandwich you
will say to me David so thank you so
much for introducing me to this
delicious delicious delicious delicious
meal what is inside this and what are
you looking at now from the exterior
you're thinking this looks pretty
mundane it doesn't look that special and
I'm telling you right now [ __ ] off it is
fantastic this bread right here cousin
this bread right here cousin is gonna
change your life because this is in
house-made bread and when you bite into
this you're gonna think your buddies are
the ass of a [ __ ] clown that is how
soft delicious moist and tender the
bread is and that's actually the
highlight of this next to this delicious
flight stuff right here this my friend
is burrata cheese if you haven't had
brought the cheese my friends it is not
mozzarella
there is mozzarella in it but it's not
much let me explain to you what burrata
cheese is burrata and I'm trying to say
it with rolling my article I want to
sound fancy as [ __ ] so burrata cheese
is going to be mozzarella on the outside
stracciatella cheese on the inside mixed
with cream
it's a mouthfeel I guess is what you
people say that it's unlike any other
it's it's cream it's exactly what that
is and inside that we also have roasted
delicious roasted chicken and I believe
it's a walnut pesto I'm not sure it's a
pesto sauce though if you haven't had
pesto before we're talking about parsley
I'm talking about herbs we're talking
about pine nuts and olive oil and
delicious parmigiano-reggiano you're not
gonna hear crunch you know why
like I said biting into the ass of a
cloud mother [ __ ] moon to ask my so
good perfectly cooked in seasoned
chicken its moist that creamy burrata
cheese oh and the flavor bomb packed
into that pesto you're not gonna even
know where the [ __ ] you're at right now
and this place too if you do go to Fiore
cafe it's cute as [ __ ] I think it's very
Parisian inspired the guy there the man
who owns this place that is the genius
behind this met him once or twice super
nice incredibly friendly even if the
food wasn't good just on that man alone
you want to eat there but the food here
which is the sandwiches are amazing they
have baked goods there as well but this
sandwich right here the chicken pesto
with burrata is why I always go back
oh man instead of a look at that creamy
burrata cheese a pesto right there I
mean there's moisture cannot exaggerate
I know when you look at this sandwich
you think it's mundane but when you eat
this you'll understand not all foods is
just about looking good for the ground
like you're [ __ ] up already you have
to think about flavors and what goes
well together and this thing is like the
perfect white bread sandwich to me it
has everything
mm-hmm and the exterior that white bread
is nice and chewy hmm oh yeah top it off
with a little rosette mmm this is good
yo a bus with this nice and crisp
fruity this is great yo man I feel extra
fancy right now cousin honking [ __ ]
what'd you say oh my god he's drinking
the rose ain't that ain't thug [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
I don't live my life thinking on thug
son I live my life eating and drinking
whatever the [ __ ] I want there's no such
thing as masculine or feminine food
[ __ ] mmm you sick again
you always sick I keep telling you only
put washed penises in your mouth I will
always say oh I just [ __ ] that cheese
oh so good oh man cheese pesto chicken
soft bread and of course you have a side
salad which game show is all about
health so
I'm a fork but [ __ ] it
oh that's a good mix greens a simple
dressing this perfect bite right here
you're calling to me it calls me poverty
bites and the last bite
little green uniform don't be like me
yeah a little bit of this Oh
sir thank you for creating the sandwich
I got to tell you your food is just as
amazing in your hospitality go to fury
cafe eat this sandwich and tell me tell
me that it tastes bad I [ __ ] dare you
if you say that this sandwich is
whatever I'm gonna [ __ ] sock you in
your belly button hello everybody
now this sandwich I have not had now
when it comes to sandwiches you cannot
talk about sandwiches if we're not
talking about New York delis now in
there's this place called language that
everybody goes to but that [ __ ] is mad
[ __ ] expensive the wait is crazy long
and it's really really delicious but you
know there are other options out there
now this is place out Eagle Rock call me
New York Deli never been there before so
this is gonna be my first taste and we
get to experience what we're having
together and this right here is gonna be
one of those first things that you see
on the hot menu when it comes to their
hot sandwiches it's their triple decker
oh [ __ ] four sides we of course had that
delicious dill pickle cuz you need a
[ __ ] pickle with the New York Deli
sandwich come on now let's open that bad
boy up so I can show you what we're
talking about look at that delicious
curved long this is the dick that girls
like where it just goes in and hits that
spot you have your choice of what side
that you want we ask for a potato salad
I'm gonna get into that but of course
I'm just teasing you right now because
we're gonna open up this rule now what I
got this with is with rye do you see
this [ __ ] monster real quick did BAM
we are talking about some of the cup
Swiss cheese in here we have coleslaw we
have corned beef and then we have
pastrami on top of that inside this is
this is what we call a [ __ ] triple
decker
and as you can see this man knows what
he's talking about specifically because
there's no [ __ ] ass little thin slices
we're talking about fat chunks of
protein oh this looks like it's calling
to me it's moist the smell of that rye
bread oh that Swiss cheese that tender
juicy brisket
look at you what what what have I done
in this life to deserve you let's give
this a go family
Oh
really delicious the pastrami and corned
beef and mingle together they're very
tender they fall apart I'll say that is
a good [ __ ] sandwich
now will I say this is the most
delicious pastrami and corned beef
sandwich I've ever had I cannot say that
but I will say this it is [ __ ]
delicious the flavor are right the right
amount of spice they're tender it falls
apart this is not a that what you eat by
yourself if you eat this [ __ ] by
yourself bro applause to you let's take
another fat bite of this and that close
lot - you need it you need it for all
that meat mmm Roe mmhmm mm-hmm
it just has so much flavor yeah I mean
the pink flavors from my nitrites which
is like a pink salt and that's how you
get that and then of course some potato
salad on the side
standard creamy delicious red onions you
taste it in there green onions pepper
Mayo nothing wrong with that take one
more bad boy bye to this yeah this is
crazy crazy let's just so much meat a
lot of fat like I always said you always
hear me say this ship you have an
abundant amount of fat in your food you
need that acidity to break it up it just
adds balance it helps them with vinegar
lemon citrus whatever it is helps out a
lot
let's tackle the sandwich one more time
again and we're gonna go from that
outside oh you see that tender [ __ ]
meat dude I'm telling you it's tender
you said it just falls apart
mm-hmm Badman it's good you know what's
interesting with this place if you read
the reviews really hive reviews four and
a half stars but the one thing that
always occurs or reoccur in those
reviews they say that the guy is kind of
mean which I don't know I don't know
that's true or not but that's I had a
very interesting experience with him
people say it's not like he's irritated
when you're ordering from him but to be
honest with you for me
Oh your [ __ ] how rude you are your
[ __ ] food's delicious I'm still
coming back we might fight or argue a
little bit doesn't mean I'm not gonna
give your bitch-ass [ __ ] money oh and
start even if you're mean I'll probably
be coming back because this right here
this right here cousin it's a delicious
sandwich it's really hard in California
to find a place that just does like
Cristina pastrami really well in my
opinion just from the stuff that I've
had out on the East Coast look I've had
this pastrami once
it was so [ __ ] good it was made by
this guy who actually works at this
barbecue joint in LA called blood cells
it was smoked it was delicious and it
was just done at the right temperature
and when you bit into it it's like the
fat melted I'm pretty sure if you guys
saw it on my Instagram stories I was
eating it every Sunday for like a month
straight but this right here there's
nothing to be ashamed about sir amazing
sandwich I ain't mad at this
now clearly I'm not gonna eat this whole
thing I ate two sandwiches before as you
guys just saw I'm not a little Japanese
girl named taiko
tuckity she and she she could probably
do it I can I don't know she has a demon
in her stomach but that wraps up this
mukbang slash food review if you guys
want me to eat something in the LA area
or try something in your area leave it
in the comments below let me know what
else you want me to eat and try out or
other places that you want me to tell
you about that I absolutely love because
if you guys don't have food variety
trust me I do and I'll eat it
[Music]
oh so is that a [ __ ] plane Oh
looks like the [ __ ] sound like a laundry
machine in the sky